der rote gigant antares ist mehr als 600
lichtjahre von der erde entfernt ein
forschungsteam hat jetzt einen trick
genutzt und ist so an äußerst
detaillierte bilder von dem roten
überriesen gelangt bei der oberflächen
kartierung des roten giganten haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
einer mehr als überraschende entdeckung
gemacht extrem turbulente vorgänge in
der atmosphäre des riesensterns mit
welchem trick diese faszinierenden
aufnahmen gelungen sind und warum dieser
trick der astrophysik völlig neue
möglichkeiten eröffnet jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
mehr als 600 lichtjahre ist der stern
antares von unserer erde entfernt der
riesige gasball bildet das zentrum des
sternbilds des skorpions und ist
außerdem das hellste objekt darin er
erscheint rötlich und wird deswegen oft
mit dem mars verwechselt antares hat
daher wohl auch seinen namen denn
antares heißt so viel wie gegen
aktuelles antares etwa 700 mal so breit
und zwölf mal so schwer wie unsere
sonne und er bläht sich derzeit immer
weiter auf denn bald in einigen tausend
jahren wird er wohl als supernova
erlöschen so die vermutung von astor
physikerinnen und physikern doch obwohl
er so hell und so groß ist ist es
forschungsteams bislang nicht gelungen
überhaupt ein detailliertes bild von
sternen außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
abzulichten er ist einfach zu weit weg
um an gute bilder von antares zu kommen
hat sich das forschungsteam aus chile
eines tricks bedient so konnten sie die
oberfläche dieses riesensterns
detailliert erfassen und sogar
bewegungen darauf messen und seine
oberfläche kartieren für die
astronomie eine absolute sensation denn
das war bislang nur bei unserer sonne
möglich und in keinem fall bei einem
stern der 600 lichtjahre entfernt ist
das ergebnis lässt staunen sie
entdeckten verwirrtes gas und zwar viel
weiter entfernt von antaris als sie
bisher durch modellrechnungen angenommen
hatten das forschungsteam schließt aus
dass diese materie durch strömungs
bewegungen dorthin gelangt ist dies
liegt auch eine weitere entdeckung nahe
die atmosphäre von antaris ist rund
sechs mal dichter als es bisherige
modelle vorhergesagt haben umwelt
strömungen die alleine
temperaturbedingt sind würden nicht so
weit nach außen reichen so die
astronomen und gastronomen stattdessen
vermuten sie dass ein komplett neuer
bisher noch unbekannter vorgang zu
diesen bewegungen in der atmosphäre von
antares führt fest steht allerdings
dass diese auf und abbewegungen der
gigantischen gas klumpen in der sternen
atmosphäre äußerst heftig sind bis zu
20 kilometer pro sekunde sind sie
schnell und reichen bis zu 1,7 stern
radien ins all hinaus dass es wirklich
riesig und fast nicht vorstellbar diese
neuen überraschenden details zum
überriesen landtages seien aber auch
nur durch das virtuelle teleskop des
very large telescope info meters der
europäischen südsternwarte eso in
chile zu sehen betonen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
denn das war der trick sie haben vier
teleskope zusammengeschaltet und hatten
dadurch eine deutlich größere
auflösung als mit nur einem einzelnen
teleskop diese beobachtungstechnik
könne man nun aber auch auf weitere
unterschiedliche stern arten anwenden
damit könnten wir tatsächlich auf
detaillierte informationen zu ihren
oberflächen und atmosphären kommen
eine völlig neue dimension für die
astrophysik jetzt können wir viel
weiter und viel genauer in die ferne
sehen als bisher möglich ist wird also
spannend was noch so alles entdeckt wird
hier bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich
dazu auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein
video zum thema und zu allen weiteren
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt man
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter mit stern auf kollisionskurs mit
dem sonnensystem entdeckt da geht es um
einen stern der unserem sonnensystem
sehr nahe kommen wird und wahrscheinlich
einen asteroiden regen auf die erde
auslösen wird spannendes thema also
nicht verpassen und drauf kriegen und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran